[Applaudissements]
il ya quatre ans mon mari a failli se
tuer sur le chemin du boulot à cause de
notre idéal de consommation alors je
suis sûr que vous vous demandez comment
il a pu en arriver là
nous étions une famille assez classique
un couple deux enfants et puis un projet
immobilier en cours
et moi je fais partie de cette
génération précaire qui enchaîne les cdd
pas très bien payé
malgré mes diplômes et lui en cdi
il se mettait une pression énorme pour
assurer la continuité financière en fait
la famille et pour aussi assurer une
consommation normale quelques objets
technologiques quelques objets plaisir
des vacances et bref il a tellement tiré
sur la corde qu'un matin notre vie a
brutalement basculé à cause de cet idéal
inatteignable en fait burn out
game over face aux conséquences
financières
mon premier réflexe a été de me tourner
vers les promotions et les produits
discount
et puis j'ai réfléchi et je me suis dit
que cette consommation n'était pas sans
conséquence sur l'autre
au bout de la chaîne l'autre au bout de
la chaîne de production par exemple
et puis finalement on est toujours
l'autre de quelqu'un et du coup j'ai
cherché des solutions radicalement
différente et ma vie a radicalement
changé
zéro déchets consommation éthique et
écologique
on s'est rendu compte à quel point une
consommation respectueuse de nous-mêmes
et et respectueuse des autres et de la
planète
il ya deux ans avec herveline on a créé
le groupe facebook gestion budgétaire
entraide et minimalisme autrement appelé
le groupe des licornes ne vous demandez
pas pourquoi qui compte donc cent mille
membres
parce que s'il existait d'un côté des
groupes écolos minimaliste zéro déchets
etc et de l'autre des groupes de gestion
budgétaire pur il n'y avait rien qui
correspondait à notre message profond
qui est
vous pouvez changer le monde même si
vous êtes un écolo du dimanche même si
vous n'avez pas de temps même si vous
êtes pauvres vous pouvez changer le
monde
même si vous êtes deux nanas comme nous
qui sont accros mnm sous un vernis à
ongles vous pouvez changer le monde même
si vous n'êtes pas un scientifique même
si vous n'êtes pas un expert même si
vous n'êtes pas un journaliste même si
vous n'êtes pas crédibles ou même si
vous n'êtes pas cohérent ou même si vous
n'êtes pas parfaitement parfait et ça
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle donc
comment on fait parce que c'est ça qui
nous intéresse un petit peu en fait
quand on est interviewé avec herveline
on nous pose toujours la question du
pourquoi
pourquoi il faut arrêter de surconsommer
et puis d'ailleurs pourquoi on
surconsomme alors il ya plein de gens
super qualifiée en fait un qui vont
répondre à toutes ces questions et en
plus nous on pense que ben vous le savez
déjà si je vous parle par exemple un des
lobbys pharmaceutiques
si je vous parle des ours qui meurt sur
la banquise à cause du réchauffement
climatique si je vous parle de la
déforestation
tout ça en fait vous le savez déjà vous
le savez déjà et pourtant vous ne
changez pas en plus bas vous vous en
fichez pas quoi ça vous fait
culpabiliser mais alors du coup quand on
culpabilise qu'on se sent pas bien on a
tendance à entrer encore plus dans la
consommation
c'est un petit peu le serpent qui se
mord la queue donc nous on a décidé de
prendre le problème de l'autre côté on a
décidé de s'attaquer aux comment donc
comment vous faire changer votre
consommation au quotidien et de manière
durable
notre objectif en fait c'est de vous
faire prendre conscience que changer
votre consommation va avoir un impact
sur vous sur votre vie sur votre
fonctionnement dès maintenant et notre
proposition pour y arriver c'est partir
de vos problématiques concrètes
donc ça peut être votre budget
effectivement le budget alimentaire vos
problèmes concrets et d'inventer
ensemble des solutions efficaces
écologique et éthique mais qui soit
adaptée à votre vie alors nous on
s'adapte à tout le monde que vous soyez
riche que vous soyez pauvres que vous
soyez écolo que vous vous en batié les
ovaires
que vous soyez au chômage que vous
bossiez 50 heures par semaine chacun
d'entre vous peut être une licorne
donc on a fini le blabla oui on passe
aux solutions ok donc on vous a préparé
une liste de quatre étapes pour devenir
un consommateur libre et heureux alors
la première étape c'est de choisir
qu'une chose une seule mais de vous
jeter à l'eau et vous savez pourquoi
c'est parce que souvent la première
action posée et libératrice et ouvre le
chemin
et la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il existe
tellement d'alternative que vous n'aurez
juste que l'embarras du choix
par exemple vous pouvez décider de
fabriquer votre produit d'entretien à
base de vinaigre de bicarbonate
vous pouvez prendre une chose que vous
consommez industrielle et la faire
désormais maison vous pouvez même lourde
et vos produits cosmétiques et vous des
quais démaquiller avec une seule huile
végétale
la seule règle c'est de prendre une
chose mais qui vous parle la deuxième
étape pour devenir un consommateur libre
et heureux c'est de se dire que on a
tous des freins et que c'est ok on a
tous en tête des oui mais moi je peux
pas parce que nani on vous a listé un
petit podium en fait des trois
principaux freins qui reviennent le plus
souvent sur la troisième marche de ce
podium nous avons l'entourage
réfractaires oui voilà c'est votre
conjoint par exemple qui ne vous suis
pas du tout dans la démarche et du coup
vous dites mais à quoi bon faire les
choses tout seul dans mon coin
on a tous inquiets d'un proche dans
notre entourage qui nous dit que le bio
c'est une méga arnaque parce que de
toute façon c'est jamais 100% bio ou
alors que ces trois fois trop cher on a
tous dans notre entourage d'une mamie ou
une belle mère ou même une mère qui
couvrent nos enfants de cadeaux made in
china sur emballés et là on se dit mais
comment je vais faire alors coulin cool
cool on respire on peut déjà peut-être
se dire deux choses la première c'est
soit le changement que tu veux voir dans
le monde on peut commencer par nous on
peut faire des choses nous tout seuls
ben c'est déjà mieux que rien et la
deuxième c'est soyons bienveillant avec
notre entourage qui est un petit peu
incrédule
moi par exemple vous m'auriez dit il ya
trois quatre ans que j'allais devenir
minimaliste vegan écolo que j'allais
même écrire un livre sur la
déconsommation et que je serai là ce
soir en train de vous parler franchement
franchement non je vous aurais pas cru
et pourtant j'y suis donc soyons
bienveillant avec notre entourage
le deuxième frein le deuxième frein sur
notre podium c'est le manque de temps
oui oui là ton truc là ça prend 20
chemin de temps et moi mes journées
après elle est donc 24 heures donc donc
voila moi j'ai pas assez de temps
peut-être que vous faites partie de
cette catégorie de population et c'est
du vécu qui bosse et 50 heures par
semaine
transport non compris et qu'ils
n'avaient absolument pas le temps de
courir quatre magasins différents le
week-end pour tout cuisiner alors quand
même la bonne nouvelle c'est que le
changement ne passe pas que par la
cuisine il ya plein de choses que vous
allez déjà pouvoir changer dans votre
quotidien et qui vous prendra 0 temps
supplémentaire par exemple le savons la
coupe menstruelle ou encore les
lingettes lavables ne vous prendront pas
une seconde de plus dans votre
fonctionnement
et puis surtout il ya une deuxième
manière d'aborder les choses s'amplifier
vous la vie oui parce qu'aujourd'hui on
a tendance à vraiment tout faire à la
carte des menus variés des jouets neufs
même si c'est au prix crédit ou encore
multiplier les activités même si on a
déjà des journées de dingue c'est
tellement ancré en nous en fait cette
exigence de perfection faut toujours
faire plus beau plus mieux voilà si on
commence dans la démarche et qu'on
réussit pas tout du premier coup
on a l'impression que c'est un échec
personnel on n'est pas bien mais en fait
la clé c'est pas de réussir à faire plus
c'est d'accepter de faire moins par
exemple si votre problème et la gestion
du linge
pourquoi ne pas envisager d'arrêter de
repasser vos culottes ou vos torchons ou
encore pour vos prochains achats de
choisir des matières qui ne nécessite
pas de repassage tout simplement est
donc le premier frein sur notre podium
le nerf de la guerre j'ai nommé le
budget est oui le bio c'est toujours
trois fois trop cher alors on panique
pas on va pas vous demander dès demain
matin de tout acheter bio nous
ce qu'on vous dit c'est plutôt alesi
petit à petit par exemple pour le budget
alimentaire ce qu'on conseille souvent
c'est de commencer à prévoir ce qu'on va
manger en se basant sur ce qu'on a déjà
sur ses placards dans ses placards c'est
mieux c'est mieux et donc une fois qu'on
a fait ça on fait une liste de ce qui
nous manque
et cette liste on essaye de la chiffrer
alors ça peut paraître bizarre mais
voilà c'est pas grave si on n'est pas à
l'euro près une fois qu'on a chiffré on
voit si ça rentre dans notre budget et
si ça rende pas eh ben on repasse par la
case menu c'est dans ce sens là que ça
marche pour le budget global c'est un
petit peu la même chose en fait on va
vous demander de lister toutes vos
charges et même les trucs auxquels vous
pensez jamais comme par exemple le
coiffeur le vétérinaire
les amendes les frais de voiture les
cadeaux les trucs comme ça vous lister
tous vous lissée sur l'année
surtout vous arrêtez de faire l'autruche
et vous regardez votre budget entre
cadieux une fois que vous aurez fait ça
vous allez voir vraiment à quoi
ressemble votre budget et qui sait vous
allez peut-être même pouvoir et paniers
épargné pour réaliser vos rêves
alors la troisième étape pour devenir un
consommateur libre et heureux c'est
largué votre culpabilité
peut-être que vous êtes dans la
situation où les perturbateurs
endocriniens vous inquiète
mais vous n'arrivez pas à arrêter de
fumer peut-être aussi que vous avez
envie de manger un maximum locale mais
que la banane c'est juste pas possible
de l'enlever de votre alimentation
ultime rondelle du monde
eh bien ce n'est pas grave vous avez le
droit d'avoir vos propres contradictions
dans nos jardins
c'est ce qu'on appelle un petit peu
l'envers de la alors là
connaissent vous savez c'est celle qui a
toujours le teint éclatant la chevelure
de rêve qui ait réussi à faire bouffer
ses enfants des brocolis vapeur c'est le
oui bio bio celle devant qui on se sent
toujours tous nuls
ben je vais vous dire un scoop cette
elle n'existe pas donc vous
pouvez tout de suite relâché la pression
est resté bienveillant avec moi même
il va y avoir des moments vous serez à
fond et il va y avoir aussi des moments
vous aurez envie de tout lâcher et c'est
juste normal et enfin la quatrième étape
pour devenir un consommateur libre et
heureux c'est entouré vous je vous
apprendrai rien si je vous dis que la
dynamique de groupe c'est un moteur
puissant donc trouver votre place
quelque part une association un
groupement citoyen une communauté
virtuelle comme la nôtre n'importe mais
ne restez pas seul alors peut-être que
vous avez encore des doutes ou que vous
pensez que c'est un petit peu une utopie
et c'est pour ça que on a eu envie de
vous raconter ce qui se passe un petit
peu quand les gens commencent à suivre
ces quelques conseils
parce que vous voyez ça fait maintenant
plus de deux ans qu'on partage tout ça
avec près de cent mille personnes
on devrait accueillir notre 100.000ème
personne normalement aujourd'hui et avec
l'aide de 200 bénévoles absolument
merveilleuse qui donne énormément de
leur temps et bien vous voyez en fait on
n'est pas là pour faire une étude
sociologique ce n'est pas du tout notre
temps notre job nous c'est de créer les
conditions du changement donc on va pas
vous présenter d'études statistiques de
durée moyenne remontée du découvert et
c'est pas notre job pas notre kiffe mais
on sait que ça marche on sait que ça
marche pourquoi on sait que ça marche
parce qu'on lit au fil des jours des
centaines et des centaines de
témoignages de personnes qui ont
complètement changé de vie changer de
métier changer de région
on voit des gens qui par exemple ont pu
prendre un congé parental alors qu'ils
imaginaient même pas pouvoir vivre avec
un seul salaire il ya quelques mois on
voit des familles qui ont réussi à
épargner suffisamment pour emmener leurs
vagues leurs enfants en vacances pour la
première fois et voilà ça c'est on n'a
pas besoin de chiffres pour voir ça
parce que c'est contagieux les gens
invitent leurs amis leur famille notre
communauté grandit de manière
exponentielle alors même que les
promotions en sont bannis et ça vu le
contexte économique actuel je peux vous
dire que c'est un excellent indicateur
parce que l'espoir est palpable on
attire nous les gens un petit peu par le
budget mais en fait quand on voit le
cheminement qui font après dans leur
conscience écologique
ils se disent six mois d'aussi loin que
je suis parti dans ses préoccupations là
aujourd'hui je me sens concerné c'est
que vraiment ça peut concerner tout le
monde
parce qu'en réalité nous sommes des
dizaines de milliers de personnes nous
mais surtout vous à avoir le même rêve
on rêve d'une société plus juste
on rêve de pouvoir faire les choses à
notre échelle malgré nos contraintes et
bien vous savez quoi en fait c'est pas
un rêve
vous avez le pouvoir vous avez le
pouvoir de financer le monde que vous
voulez voir avec vos achats et on va le
faire tous ensemble de l'intérieur avec
nos contraintes et en laissant de côté
la culpabilité de tout ce qui reste
encore à faire parce qu'on est partout
de tous les âges de tous les milieux des
hommes des femmes de tous les métiers de
toutes les couches de la société et que
c'est ça notre force
nous sommes la clé alors pour conclure
et parce que d'autres en parlent bien
mieux que nous on aimerait vous lire un
témoignage d'une licorne qui s'appelle
thaïs et qui a répondu à la question
qu'est-ce que laly corps ni pour toi au
fond un cri du coeur un hurlement sans
bruit un regard qui veut guérir de
l'amour qui veut encore sortir de
l'énergie de vie qui se débat
indéniablement contre le désespoir la
peur l'incohérence l'ignorance
l'insensibilité tout en essayant de
faire perdurer l'insouciance merci
beaucoup
et maintenant levé vous et changer le
monde
[Applaudissements]